in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matthew
and Heather are with us hey how are you
good welcome welcome where are you from
Minneapolis oh cool cool our team's
gonna be up there next week doing an
event do you have your tickets yet we
sure do very cool I was gonna give you
something but you're said very good
so you're here to do a debt free scream
in Nashville we are I love it how much
of you guys paid off
forty-three thousand dollars phenomenal
and how fast did you do that 11 months
Wow and range of income during that time
take home we're about 145,000 cool what
do you guys do for a living I sell a
custom software design and development
mm-hmm and I'm a client services manager
very good oh you guys are doing great
congratulations so what kind of debt was
the 43,000 we had student loans a car
payment a timeshare and then a little
bit of miscellaneous in there as well
you were kind of normal yeah kinda
normal so what happened a year ago that
changed your life because you guys are
now weird yeah yeah Matt's always been
really interested in your stuff and he
kind of started the snowball I guess on
his own years ago you sneaky yeah I had
thought we were normal so I really
hadn't paid a lot of attention to it but
I had come across a video of your
daughter speaking at our church in
something about when she read the the
proverbs 6 about the gazelle and running
from the hunter I don't know what it was
but it struck me and I came home at
night and I told Matt I want to see all
of it like let's look at our debt let's
see what we can do and I couldn't
believe after 7 years of paying student
loans how much I still owed and that was
enough to kick us into gear and we said
we can do this in two years and then we
just kept going and yeah here we are so
Matthew loves Rachel Cruise cuz he got
she turned his wife on right yeah I
loved it so she comes home and she's
excited and you're like yes fist pump
right oh yeah smile ear to ear let's do
it yeah I was ready yeah I'm sitting
here waiting on you yeah this is awesome
I had our finances already laid out and
we are ready to start prioritizing Matt
and then well Heather being on board
that kicks it into overdrive right oh
absolutely
cool very fun well congratulations you
guys that is a blast
how does it feel no payments yeah it's
it's weird it's awesome it's a different
place so what was the hardest part of
this for you guys well it was definitely
putting the envelope system into
practice so I had a great week at work
and it was a Thursday and I wanted to
take my wife and daughter out for dinner
and we went to reach for the envelope
and there's nothing in there oh so we
stayed home we grilled and made ooh No
there it is that's when it's real isn't
it yeah when you said when you learn to
say no something causes you to say no
yep there was that self-control muscle
yeah that's that's a muscle that has to
be built if you're gonna win oh very
cool you guys so what advice do you give
to people that are listening that they
got $45,000 they've been dragging along
never gonna get out of this I'm stuck
what you do what are you telling the
secret to getting out of debt is I think
focus and accountability I think like
matt said that first time you reach for
the envelope and the money's not there
you kind of have to be on the same team
to say yeah but then tomorrow's Friday
that's when money goes back in the
envelope so we're gonna have to wait one
more day and have that accountability we
thought with each other and then the
focus once we started looking long-term
and the idea of having our house paid
off before ability like that's a real
thing and that is the motivation for us
definitely yeah you'd be right on track
very cool very cool
will congratulations you guys very very
well done I love it that's good
good insight and thanks for making the
trip all the way from Minneapolis course
you get to be in Nashville so there's a
nice little nice little bonus in this
deal here but but very very nice all
right Matthew and Heather Minneapolis
Minnesota $43,000 paid off in 11 months
making 145 a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
I love that very well done
Congrats Congrats Congrats hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and say
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind